support for the dollop comes from our
x-bar a whole food protein bar made with
100% whole ingredients these are awesome
they are awesome you get we both got a
box I but I've been a fan before the box
my hope you've already gone dude I
really do you knew what they were before
you got them yeah yeah no I ate them a
lot on my last job they have well
they're super like healthy and protein
filled
they also they're also like like they're
made with like natural stuff yeah and
simple they put all the ingredients
right egg whites staple totally all just
change it up real fruit spices yeah
cacao get your [ __ ] hand away from my
face and taste good which you would
surprisingly you okay healthy things
often get a knock but it's taste good
you you love them there's eleven
different delicious flavor varieties of
which Gareth probably likes all gluten
free soy free dairy free yep
no added sugar artificial flavors
preservatives I but they're real good if
you dip them in nacho sauce I've been
hiking a lot I take them on hikes yeah
it's great when you get to the top and
you're just sitting there thinking about
how you might die because you've worked
out too hard
what and then you eat a bar suicide pan
you run down and you trip on a rock and
you see yourself falling face
buddy-buddy last minute roll-off in the
grass and a guy walks by and says are
you okay what are you talking about you
don't look up and you just say [ __ ] I
have their God so they're great for like
Gareth I will have them at the office
Wow you have them grab one on a plane
bring on a plane they're great pre or
post-workout egg white protein stands
out as a source of protein so that's
super easy for your body to absorb
that's what I'm saying yeah I push it
through my arm sometimes so obviously
Gareth which one's your favorite one do
a favor
I like they have like a chocolate sea
salt and then there
blueberry - I don't know they're all
really good they're all there's not
they're like similar yeah there's a lot
of good ones
all right good one I think that seasonal
rx for 25% off your first order visit
our x-bar dot-com / dollop and enter
promo code dollop at checkout Gareth
loves it
Thanks I'm also a big fan okay and of
course you guys we want to say you're
listening to the dollop this is a
bi-weekly American history podcast each
week I tea drinker I'm drinking tea and
you're not pizza eater I had pizza
before this and you didn't what I had
all of and pepperoni pizza and and my
favorite traffic sign Oh bear Dave
Anthony reads a story from American
history to his friend Gareth Reynolds
who has no idea what the topic is going
to be about when I ain't meat that used
to be my go-to pepperoni black olive we
are also brought to you by fabfitfun so
if you're thinking about getting
something for your lady for Valentine's
Day this is a great way to do it
fabfitfun they send you a box here's the
move for 20 order the box and then you
just buy like a little bag like a gift
bag and you empty thing everything from
the box into the gift bag like if you
want to get to that level of shadiness
you're a vet you're able to so they send
it's just it's full of tons of stuff
that is a name-brand stuff like I said
that we got a poncho we didn't my lady
got a poncho she got mascara she got
stave two shader I think they market
sports markings there's not under-eye
blackening my wife's a quarterback since
you got the box so it's full size
products it's not sample products
they're they're cutting edge stuff as
they say it's the great value honey I'm
auditioning for the Falcons later the
cost of the box is you get like 200
bucks for the stuff or something like
it's pretty crazy they don't repeat
boxes its products in the box each time
they send you a new box
yeah it's seasonal so you know it's
great you love fashion stuff and beauty
and home and fit my mother got my mother
left yesterday and when she's getting
like when she was leaving she was so
excited about the poncho yeah yeah like
I said four times a year it's for $49.99
a box so jump on board a fab fit fun
it's fabfitfun calm so I used to be your
website we just got yeah I gave it to
him
we just got our fabfitfun boxes our
ladies loved it my case my wife in his
case is mom go use wait all right code
to get $10 off you're my peak of sadness
yep first box try a fab buffet my butt
is this how you realize you're pathetic
someone just mentions it in an ad I gave
some to my beautiful wife and family and
you to your mom who is visiting so good
a fat fit too fun calm to subscribe and
start getting the box for a and they
send women to your home life well-lived
use promo code dollop to get $10 off
your first box that's the product we
have a matchmaking sponsor that's
products valued at $200 for only $39.99
again good a fab fit fun calm and use
code doll am i unlovable to get $10 off
your first fabfitfun boggs and then
we'll see what happens
with care we've got to play the theme
something didn't we uh let's play we're
all out of order let's play now what
it's okay to have a candida called it
quote is jam-packed
sip arguments so get start talking I was
I was about to I was about to say we're
going to Thailand but these guys these
guys again playing again we do it keeps
playing twice but these guys the only
podcast that plays the intro twice the
little dumb dumb clubs have not updated
their website or something go to a
famous see it that must be an event so
anyway we'll be in Thailand in June June
yeah ko samui I've been there I've been
to question me yeah is it great it's
great yeah it's a great little beach
island how long did you stay there
five days yeah really and you were fine
when you were there how much of a
clamour was there for a podcast festival
so basically it's gonna be us and a
little dum dum Club you can go to a
little game through the eighteenth
little dum-dum club.com slash Koh Samui
which is Koh si am UI I think you just I
think you just need to get it's a
hundred bucks for tickets and then you
get you get a code that you can get a
little cheap off the cheap hotel
actually yeah as it's called 13th
through 18th in June so they'll be
stand-up there'll be a little dum dum
podcasts we'll do a podcast yeah so
it'll it's gonna be a lot of stuff a lot
of a lot of good like Nick Cody went
last year and no good yeah good time had
by all
so who wouldn't wanna go take a vacation
with a podcast Hey come vacation with a
podcast and then and then you know go to
dolla podcast.com and you can check out
all of our tour dates San Francisco
Portland Indianapolis we added a second
show in Annapolis Seattle Portland San
Francisco any not the second shows okay
I Love You Man and I will see you later
I should do this podcast to keep not
shutting up about now Dave this is a
smallest November 17th 1876 okay we
haven't done a small up in a while yeah
we're rusty Rutherford nephew I'm mister
nephew I'm doctor uncle was born in the
District of Columbia
okay he was named after Rutherford B
Hayes who at the time of his birth
Rutherford nephews birth was waiting to
find out the results of the presidential
election so sorry lecture me Hayes was
his uncle no he was just named after him
you just think it was his uncle cuz his
last name is nephew they're not related
confused him were under two sentences
because his name is so [ __ ] up they're
not related his name again
Rutherford nephew he's aimed after
Rutherford be Hayes president okay to be
yeah who's his dad's it didn't start
well for a guy with your brain well I
mean you know and then if you add in
that drug use in high school in college
it just sort of Oh Dave's losing the
hoodie his his parents were
french-canadian
rufus had two brothers and two sisters
rufus did
we're sorry Rutherford buddy you just
got me to handle what's happening
his father had found had gone into the
Civil War in the Vermont volunteers so
he was up in Vermont I guess and he
jumped into the war with those boys
Rutherford uncle's father Rutherford
nephews dad Rutherford nephews dad right
I didn't think of this would be much as
a problem is that clearly it's going to
be so during the war he was protecting
DC with with the in the battle there and
ended up with a very serious lung
disorder I couldn't figure out what it
was but I soon we got after What's in we
get anything no I guess I bet he was
probably near fire smoke situation
breathe it in and lack long sad lung
so after he's eating out of hospitals
around DC for years the family stayed in
DC after the war but not going well the
marriage ends before Rutherford's born
okay sure
so when Rutherford's eight months old he
was baptized but st. Joseph's Catholic
Church screwed up an accident we it's we
did Church of Satan and accidentally
baptized him Rufus nephew okay so that's
why okay so he's baptized Rufus nephew
accident it would just be so crazy for
us to go to God and see if he could undo
that do you mind if he just sticks with
brofist I apologize do you mean his
name's Rutherford so they just kind of
stuck it does his dad's health kept
deteriorating and then his dad died on
February 22nd 1881 was just four and a
half years old okay so not much is known
about the life of young Rufus at some
point in the early 1890s his mom moved
the family to Chicago okay but it
doesn't sound like Rufus was with her
because records of his life in Arizona
start to pop up at that point
okay he also had a new name
okay totally totally wasn't Rutherford
so understandable the most
understandable name change in the
history of people yeah sure he's now
going by Jim Thomas interesting okay
another route he's a teenager at the
time so people in Arizona searched a kid
Thomas interesting tweak sure sure kid
Thomas yeah that didn't last long though
Jim explained how his new nickname came
to be quote I used to like tobacco right
well and when I was just a kid I lit
into the camp of the hashknife outfit in
northern Arizona and was going on the
roundup for a month so I just laid in a
supply tobacco twelve pounds a climax
tied in a gunnysack
and a full bar tied to my saddle handy
as a rifle in Deer country at the end of
25 days when I chewed every leaf of that
tobacco there wasn't a puncher in their
outfit that wasn't calling me climax Jim
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay okay climax
let's back up a little here okay so he
got a big thing that's the thing of
chewing tobacco the gun so he got us a
huge brick of chewing tobacco and
because he chewed so much of it his
nickname was climax yeah because that's
the name of the chewing tobacco climax
twenty-five pounds of it he chews you
twenty-five pounds of tobacco that's oh
no sorry twelve okay twelve still say
still way too much tobacco yeah like
he's showing off at that point well they
named him after the brand
he wasn't named after it until after he
did it all here's also a bunch of stuff
climax stuff oh okay
interesting so he now he's known as
climax Jim when Jim was just max plug uh
oh one of them's called climax plug
that's for something else oh boy that's
a she's wearing a little of it well back
then you know you could draw women
wearing it
when Jim was just 17 he was arrested for
selling a dozen stolen cows to a
slaughterhouse
okay but the adobe jail had a flaw the
Adobe jail yeah what was the law so that
night Jim was able to dig out using a
pocketknife okay so he seriously is it
an Adobe how did he do it well he cut
through the walls like all the other
guys sir just a few months later on July
4th that's him 18 yeah on a July 4 the
1894 he stole a horse okay but County
Sheriff John Rimrock Thompson everyone's
got a nickname okay
caught up with Jim and Pleasant Valley
and started the journey Rufus uncle's on
Rimrock started the journey to take Jim
to the jail and globe City what is
happening it's terrible things taking
more than a day they camp for the night
sheriff Thompson chained climax Jim to a
post okay not a good move Jim broke a
link in the chain and took off on foot
okay the next morning sheriff Thompson
said about hunting Jim down which took a
while he was captured a few miles away
and this time taken all the way to jail
okay
what was this jail made out of ice well
Jim crime extreme was stuck in the jail
for a couple of months until he got his
hand on a spoon and used it to remove
the mortar from around enough bricks to
make a big hole to crawl through again
the luxury of first no man knows when
you could spoon out of a jail I mean
truly that was like before they were
like oh no don't give him a spoon ah
bugger so locals there gave him the
nickname the spoon kid we called him
climax Pune uncle nephew [ __ ] so off Jim
off off Jim goes he escapes he stole a
horse to make his getaway he rode the
horse hard until it gave out and
he stole another horse and kept riding
climax rode the horse art that's right
he was caught just before you got to
Benson for the horse stealing and the
escape he was sentenced to one year in
prison he did not escape from Yuma
Territorial prison and served his entire
time okay that's right
the day he was bringing me with his damn
hands that's right the day he was
released he walked out to discover a
sheriff was waiting to take him to jail
you're under arrest again for previously
stealing a horse on Indian Reservation
okay this time he was sentenced to six
months in the penal County Jail and he
was released in 1896
now climax Jim managed to steer clear of
the law for two years until June 1898
when deputy Joe bargeman arrested him
for stealing cattle okay so he's got a
pattern the sheriff took him to st.
John's Jail that didn't last long while
the deputy and another man were eating
dinner Jim picked the lock on the cell
door stole the deputy's horse and rode
off Lord so they are just he's the
[ __ ] competence he's the best
but that's amazing what he picked a lock
that's pretty good come on with the
dinner this is like this is movie stuff
again it's first this is movie stuff
yeah Clemmie
clemont's gym had reputation as a lock
picker after he was locked in a cell he
would tell the sheriff that he planned
to bust out before morning what and the
next morning he would be gone damn it
one time he picked a lock sat in the
sheriff's chair and smiled at the lawmen
when he showed up to work the next
morning well how do I told you yeah
it'll calm the climax Jim for nothing
also I came on the chair so then climax
oh wait yep makes sense
hello oh you're rooming with orgasm
Ernie oh good lord
oh boy so Jim was now getting famous for
all his escapes one newspaper wrote
quote climax Jim is easily the most
slippery jailbird in the southwest
another wrote it is an old saying that
the third time is the charm but climax
by the way if that's not the saying
that's not the third time is the charm
you know how they say it that early bird
well he's most likely catching that one
the third time is the charm Jim
well you're reading extra words paper is
an old saying that the third time is the
charm but climax has been arrested and
tried about 47 times and he has always
succeeded in getting in the clear okay
climax Jim was getting so well known in
the area that he had business cards Wow
what it just says it's just a peel box
Clifton Arizona get in touch with them
besides Authority
Rufus Neffe he's gone with his official
Rufus nephew IMAX Jim so the idea with
the PIO box is just fan mail I guess I
don't know exactly what that is what are
you handing your card out for if your
whole thing is getting out of jail
everything I read was like I don't know
weight of a business card but maybe he
just you know you know you do a job you
handsome in your card or maybe when you
break out of jail you leave your car
love that love that move right man of
that Neer's day if you'd like to blow me
in person meet me at p o-- box if you'd
like to blow me in person go box eight
one eight so lost my place stall stall
you know Dave I think if you know you
know what's funny nowadays is um you
know what I hear something funny you
know the other day I was in a lift
yeah you ever been in one of these these
guys this guy he's not from here uh-huh
yeah so I'm talking with a guy yeah and
the guys talking to me yeah and he's not
from here uh-huh
we're talking and okay I got okay we're
good that was great that was good hey
yeah you're what's known as an improv
hey they call they call me Rufus for a
reason they call you improv
yeah that's the reason they come on ears
day 18 oh wait the twelve items in let's
check out line boy they're not enforced
on that are they okay go ahead scamp on
New Year's Day Day 1899 Jim was arrested
for burning brands burning brands and
that's ending other people yes so he
steals he steals cattle and then he he
changes the brand so it looks like his
brand a really fun process for the cows
double branding they're usually the
second brand they're like I didn't want
to be in the fraternity there's a
rebranding yeah a rebranding sucks
original branding also not that great
know what Spike TV just went through so
he's you know rebranding he gets caught
last about six weeks in jail before he
and three other convicts escaped on foot
but they kick through the walls didn't
say how they got out okay I'm gonna go
black they were caught a few days later
three weeks later the local blacksmith
was called to put Jim and Jim in leg
shackles okay two days after that one of
the jailers noticed that the leg
shackles were broken don't touch it I
love you that the leg shackles the
listeners that's gonna send a little
crazy the leg shackles were broken okay
so before he did anything he so he calls
the blacksmith to come back to fix them
but before the blacksmith get there gets
there Jim climbs over the wall and
escapes sorry so he had them on so a
blacksmith comes and puts shackles and
shackles right yeah and then two days
later the jailer sees that the leg
shackles are broken right so he calls
for the blacksmith to come back and fix
them within that time he jumps the fence
but he jumps the fence run but they had
a guy wait
okay smart finally so he break the leg
shackles must and so he's just keeping
him on to be like I'm waiting for my
turn
yeah he must have so they caught him a
few minutes later sure still good run
yeah a friend post bail for him this
time so he gets out and immediately
steals some cattle from a cattle company
he's got a bit of a problem the cattle
were unguarded at the time he just saw
much cows out there oh man so he said he
was just being friendly
yeah and hurting the cows until the new
owner was boy this is like if there was
a cops this would have been on cops back
then sir what are you doing officer it's
not what it looks like no no I'm just
hurting these five cattle because I
couldn't find their owner that's the
equivalent of well no my buddy just lost
his keys and said that if I jump started
it then I could take it well I don't
remember my buddy's name no is that him
yeah that's him around this time he
looks like he that's Dave Grohl yeah so
so he's cruising around with these cows
apparently he just keeps going looking
with his owner because pretty soon he's
heard of them all the way to New Mexico
still can't our life cylinder can't find
the others is he calling them look
anyway you can't call we gonna call you
he's got a run around honor to anybody
I'm starting to think I'm gonna have to
have them when he got to New Mexico he
formed the star bar circle cattle
company he was president superintendent
range boss Wrangler Ron cook and the
Board of Directors sure okay he handled
a lot of the business how did he work
with himself
well yeah really good too made a lot of
good meals for himself okay sometimes
little yellow sure we have another
birthday in the office but the range
boss of the actual Cattle Company took
them from was following on the cello
missing cows he also knowing who climax
Jim was notified the sheriff in Apache
County to look for climax Jim okay who
was arrested and taken back to Arizona
okay
now you should see what it's a bit of a
troubled youth he's not great he's got
some issues so this is the this is one
of the jails that he was labeled it okay
well yeah I mean I feel like a break
he's got holes in it yeah look a lot so
so he's taken back to Arizona
apparently he climax Jim smelled quite
bad because the lawmen decided he needed
a bath
great this better be attacked so he had
his clothes taken off and he was given a
bar soap and a brush and then they put
him in a horse trough okay sure as one
does now next to a horse trough there
was a horse but he'd so naked climax Jim
jumped on and just galloped off Wow [ __ ]
when you watch him well our biggest
mistake was assuming he went to do this
nude not hurt oh yeah but balls my balls
my balls my balls my balls there's a man
named climax saying my balls on a stolen
horse through town yes he's naked
yes he's naked it is said that he rode
through two towns completely naked okay
so clothes are not a priority I mean
he's hitting the ground like a
terminator yeah yeah he doesn't need it
yeah a nude figure out clothes later
he's arrested again later that year so
he was on the lam for a while with that
[ __ ] he was on the horse for a while
this time he went to trial sure here's
the courthouse that's always fun is it
just gonna be labeled like another kids
town adventure courthouse courthouse
sure so he he produces witnesses who
swore the crime had been committed in
Apache County okay and he was acquitted
and then he was immediately arrested in
Apache County or for stealing the same
cattle okay so so then Jim Jim produced
witnesses who saw where the crime had
been committed in Graham County and he
was acquitted do it he's the [ __ ]
best
in 1902 he showed off his safecracking
abilities when a Clifton
storekeeper ordered a burglar-proof safe
that's where he lives right climax Jim
happened to be there when the safe
arrived so he started fiddling with the
dial the crowd gathered and after 30
minutes he opened the door wow so he's
[ __ ] got some game how's he doing it I
just think he's one of those guys he has
a skill he makes it happen he's starting
to look pretty sweet he looks a little
bit like what's his name Sam Elliot yeah
well he's got the mustache well I mean
really when you say someone looks like
Sam Elliot aren't you just saying to
have a big bushy mustache yeah that's it
they look good in a hat and have a big
bushy mustache climax Jim continued
getting arrested and escaping for years
in 1907 he was on trial for altering a
check okay during the trial the lawyers
got into a rather intense argument while
everyone was focused on the argument Jim
wandered over and picked up the check
from the prosecutors desk and put it in
his mouth because he already had a big
watch oh okay
so he just shoved it in so everyone's no
one noticed because the argument was
going on who's arguing like wrestlers
the lawyers are yelling at each other
and he walks over to evidence and puts
the check in his tobacco mouth what's on
the prosecutors table so he just grabs
it in crams in his mouth this might just
be a case of either he's invisible or
confident after order was restored to
the court the trial continued the hell's
that jack at some point the judge asked
to see the evident I'd like to see this
check please but no one could find it
Jim do you have it Jim just sat there
chewing his tobacco slash evidence and
he was found not guilty due to a lack of
evidence
okey-dokey yay legend was it that as he
left the courtroom he spit the check
into the judges spittoon nice I don't
believe that that's what you take issue
with yeah
dude ate a check you're worried about
where he spit it Jim had a longtime lady
friend and they married in 1907 her name
was Virginia Gonzales okay the marriage
was briefly delayed when he was arrested
and and then escaped sure well he had a
marriage to get to
marriage did not last long they were
soon divorced and he was on his way to
his next wife hey how long until he was
saying I want to go back to jail and I'm
not talking about that marriage hello
[Laughter]
and he married a relative named Gertrude
nephew he married a relative also named
nephew the nephews were relatives that
sounds obvious how is he related to her
must be cousin or something I'd like you
to meet the nephews they're cousins I
mean you could marry a cousin back then
I bet some place you still can be you oh
you can don't believe me I've googled in
a bunch you can marry I think of seven
states you can still do a cousin
marriage I'm always googling that yeah
um they got married in 1910 and had a
son Stanley Stanley was not healthy they
moved to San Diego and had two daughters
so Jim got out of the when he had kids
and wife he got hung up the crime
business and he and he got into the well
dig in business okay and then in
September 1921 he was digging a well and
it had collapsed and he died oh geez he
should have stuck to crime Jesus so this
dude is just the first hacker uh okay
don't okay me don't placate me
I hate being played
oh yeah you want to see his grave sure
buzzing to see his grave his gravestone
what is it in Russian it's so old yeah
it's all old and even got a little piece
chipped out of it where he probably
trying to dig out of the grave yeah
break one last break out boy anyway he
didn't make it
that's a fun that's a nice fun little
small up Dave thank you
a little small up for the people 44 40
but in those years what oh I guess 1921
but what's the life expectancy back then
it's gotta be fun it's gonna be more
than 45 maybe it isn't though I mean I
bet it's more than that but not by much
in the 1920s yeah you gotta have another
chance a 55 55 60 I mean it's before
Social Security so people are just
eating their own feet to live at that
age five years we'll be back oh yeah
we're a little back there because we got
to get rid of that yes that's not
helping people I let daddy's fuse again
it's so easy to do I just gotta go a
little negative and you'll be like let's
party all right you can follow Gareth on
Twitter Reynolds Gareth and Instagram we
have a dolt of the dollop on Instagram
I'm on Instagram Dave underscore Anthony
underscore dollar podcast show dates a
podcast that's our comm and then we're
on Facebook we have a subreddit the
dollop all right stuff people talk in
there about stuff and sure sometimes I
banned them sure your ought to do David
yep don't talk [ __ ] all right good night
we signed jars